what did studying Quentin Tarantino
teach you about storytelling haha what
it couldn't teach me about storytelling
that the his his attention to detail on
every level I think that's what I think
that's what Quinn taught me like you
have to pay attention to everything it's
all important the fact that he has the
kangaroo from Pulp Fiction on the shelf
and Jackie Brown and I believe in
hateful eight those little those little
things not only is it cool but it's it's
cool here you know because I kangaroo
meant so much back then in Pulp Fiction
to bring it now and gives the viewer
something to look for look forward to I
mean that's his type of thing but uh
what's another example of the detail DM
oh like uma shoes her little tiger a6
which I've got a little white ones on on
the when she walks across the glass I
think it says you on the bottom of
it we're off one of the other like
little things like that that speaks to
her character it is amazing you don't
notice as it floats by maybe but we
still pick it up as humans right our
brain still maybe not the you on
the sneaker specifically but the
attention to detail shows right I should
think of another good example of that
but he's there's nothing out of place in
a Tarantino script or a Tarantino film
or even in his marketing I mean he's a
master pretty much across all aspects of
filmmaking and I think I think that's
what I learned about
would I hope to carry with me is the
attention to detail and then there's
also the part of Quentin where people
want to hear him speak he's a so it's
the same with like Kevin Smith where
like they're so fascinating to listen to
they are fascinating and that's not true
with a lot of directors but those two
yes and deaf right Quentin like there's
no subject thanks so much you look again
when you're listening to somebody or
watching somebody do what they love to
do or talk about something that they
love and there's that knowledgeable
about it it's you're just engrossed it's
it's amazing he's fantastic but you
don't so here's a great example I'm not
an f1 fan right
I don't follow it Senna's my favorite
documentary I love that documentary it's
so good I don't care about the racing
right so this is why I like revisiting
Tarantino films whether you're a fan or
not to sit and just look at the majesty
that he creates is fascinating he he's
he's just fascinating and in you to
something in an interview that he pays
attention to detail and he'll go I think
you use the example of the pub and
listen to people speak how much research
did you put in on Quentin and also on
Rick just just you were already a fan of
their films you knew their work but I
mean how much more were you were you
doing not a lot actually and I was very
specific not to I watched their films I
didn't want to know about personal stuff
I didn't want to dig into I didn't want
to know that stuff so again going back
to that innocence and the the stories to
come out as I sat with people I wanted
that to be fresh to me and what and what
resonated so that I give if I heard that
in the news somewhere else or read it
somewhere it would have been I feel like
deluded so I was I was very careful to
not or I thought I should say I fought
not looking at certain things all right
because there's grape there's great
books on Quinton on
style and on his history and I I almost
did I was like maybe I should be better
informed but it's somebody else's
opinion of and I just kind of wanted
whoever I was sitting with I wanted
theirs I didn't want another opinion to
to be in my brain or something to be
said and I've heard it elsewhere so I
dismiss it right so I was very careful
to not do too much research yeah I find
that interesting because it's sometimes
very helpful in getting the best out of
someone because there's a sense of
discovery if you know too much and then
again at the personal life I find that
clouds I mean just being in the world
you hear about quitting turns you know
right so there is already enough there
that you almost have to you know plate
your muffs on tonight hear about him
when a film comes out or what how people
talking about filmmaking ever in general
or daily life actually comes out so
there's definitely there's enough out
there about Quinn I I didn't want to I
didn't want to flood more right I have
since yeah it's fine I agree I think
sometimes knowing who someone's spouses
or whatever it clouds the interview
because now you have that in your mind
if you don't know that personal stuff
then you now you're just talking about
the work if that's what you're there for
if you're there for something where it's
more personal than I'd be different but
if it's about the work I I agree I think
that would be so a great example
actually is with regard to Huma so
there's so much in the news about luma
and after that the car accident
oh they've they've fallen out they hate
each other there's there's so many
different stories about that
relationship and when the truth came out
from uma it was okay that that that's
what the truth is right so and actually
she came out and said something out the
post the Weinstein stuff I don't have a
shoe with Quentin so you know I've issue
with the fact that the footage was was
withheld from me right and they had a
falling out it was a terrible thing that
happened
and life happens right sure but they
have since come back to each other and
they're their friends and what have you
so if I did do too much investigating
into into that story there's a lot of
conjecture out there about it and it may
have skewed how I took what I learned in
the process all right it also even
reading comments I think can consume
because sometimes you're not sure where
is this person someone on the inside is
it just some person that's delusional
though who actually is close to that
person where they have the correct
information yeah there's just a lot of
voices right right in the world today
especially with social media and such
that so then your advice maybe for
another documentarian is go in but don't
don't go in blind of course but then
don't go in maybe with too much because
it's better for the discovery I think so
I think so with regard to people right
mom that's a good point right if you're
documenting if it's a historical
documentary or something like that
that's much different obviously I'd read
everything on that subject right and
then you balance out everything you take
in but um I think when it comes to
people we're not our culture isn't very
respectful of that so in order to be
respectful I think you need to hear it
from from the person right I don't think
the the research applies necessarily
you